greetings everyone this is Rob Sanders
and today I'm going to present Facebook
advertising tips and strategies so thank
you for joining today we're gonna cover
a number of tips to help you gain a
better advantage on advertising on
facebook so let's get right to it with
tip number one and with tip number one
not all advertisements need to sell
something so remember you have different
objectives on Facebook you can advertise
an event you can promote a customer
story you can send traffic to your
website or you can get them to download
and out so it all goes back to your
objectives so if we go to Facebook and I
want to create an ad remember my first
option is to create an objective so you
have awareness you have consideration
you have conversion so depending on what
you want somebody to do that's the
objective you're gonna choose so just
keep that in mind when you're setting up
your campaign on Facebook you need to
align your objective with what you want
people to do tip number two we want to
use Facebook messenger for advertising
so facebook Messenger is a feature that
can be used with advertising on Facebook
and it's a good tool it's a good
practice because it allows you to as the
advertiser to commute with individuals
directly so it's a feature that you
should take advantage of because it
allows you to quickly engage with your
target audience so that's the beauty of
leveraging Facebook messenger with your
advertising the communication tool is
available and for you to engage with
your target audience so it's great for
not only interacting but taking care of
any other objections that they have is
it on as an audience or prospective
client so you can answer any concerns
they have right away so it's a lot more
personal and interactive than other
forms of advertising because you're
directly communicating with your
audience tip 3 use video advertisements
I can't stress this enough video is very
engaging in fact it's not only engaging
but it's very easy to use so we go to
Facebook really Facebook is telling us
for video all we need to do is have
basically a phone handy and an app and
just to be able to upload it so with
Facebook video you can really drive
awareness and you can really drive sales
I mean you can really make some really
splashy videos on Facebook all you need
is a mobile camera so with Facebook
videos it's really very easy to create
you just got to be creative that's
really the key to videos you know
they're gonna be engaging to the end
user say something do something that's
gonna really grab their attention and
get them to do what you want them to do
so these are just some of the examples
you can see on Facebook and you can see
how creative advertisers are getting you
know clear call-to-action great video or
great imagery good promotional use so
there's a lot you can do with video and
really make it interactive so I can't
stress video enough as an option for
Facebook it really is one of the better
features of Facebook advertising and
really very limited use of resources all
you need is that web camera and app in
the ability to upload that video that's
really it for video advertisements so
keep in mind and the reason why I'm
harping on those video ads is they tend
to outperform your traditional Facebook
image ads and other formats like the
carousel or the presentation mode so
there's other types of formats on
facebook video tends to give it that
extra edge because it's very interactive
and in the form of interactivity comes
engagement so in this example you know
people are going to react they're gonna
comment they're gonna share the video
and that's what you want as an
advertiser you want to grab as much
reach as possible towards your target
audience and so video will help you do
that it will help you not only engage
with the person but allow that video to
be shared and expand your reach towards
your target audience
so remember video can range from a few
seconds all the way up to 120 minutes so
you're really gonna get more views
regardless of how long the video is
because it's just gonna be so
interactive so just keep that in mind it
does
have to be full on 120 minutes it could
be you know anywhere from one to five
minutes you know to me that's probably a
good range but just know that you have
that lead way if you wanted to so
remember
video ads always perform better than
single image ads or other type of image
ad formats on Facebook and they also
perform better when they have subtitle
support so just keep that in mind as
well because you may have you know
individuals watching the video from you
know different countries speaking
different languages say tip for when
you're placing your advertisement where
you place your advertising play an
important role and deciding how many
people come across it so Facebook offers
a number of different options to choose
from so remember you got the news feed
you got instant articles right column
you got suggested videos so you got a
lot of options at your disposal there's
lots of other options too so you can
have Facebook actually automatically
place your ads or you can specifically
tell Facebook where you want to place
your ads and that's all part of the
Facebook set up so if we go to Facebook
and then we go to create your campaign
so if we clues ad sets here is where
we're gonna be able to choose our
placement if we click on choose
placement we'll be able to you know be
able to allow Facebook to place it or we
can edit the placement specifically so
just keep that in mind you have a lot of
different options here again feeds and
stuff articles in-stream videos right
calm you even have Instagram so you have
a lot of options available to you so my
recommendation of Facebook's
recommendation is always go with the
auto placement but you can specifically
choose your placement if you want to
plan you're setting up your campaign so
start the advertising on the newsfeed
could be recommended the newsfeed is
where you're probably gonna get your
most eyeballs most users spend most of
their time there and it has the highest
chance of grabbing their attention so
the newsfeed could be a good place to
start again you can have it at Auto
placement and your ads may be there as
well
or you can specifically choose just the
newsfeed or other placements so tip 4
just be careful where you place your ad
it's really important you want to place
your ad where you can
get balls so tip 5 Facebook ads also
offer you the option to advertise on
Instagram so you have that option
available to you as I mentioned it tip 4
you have the option to advertise these
stories carousel ads photo ads and video
ads so again that's all part of the ad
setup when you go to choose your
placements here you got Instagram feed
you're gonna Instagram stories and again
with both of those placements on
Instagram you can work with several
different types of ads including that
carousel ad including that video ad so
just keep that in mind that Instagram is
an option for you take advantage of it
there's a lot more eyeballs on Instagram
these days and it plays off nicely with
what you're trying to do with Facebook
so go ahead and give it a try okay so
let's take a quick break from the first
few tips we went over and let's take a
look at an end
so it's an ad break time so let's take a
look at this ad this is by New Scientist
and so what makes this ad so great well
there's been a lot of shake-up in the
world today about fake news you know
what is fake news so New Scientist is
actually playing off of that they're
mentioning hey fake news not in our
world so they're actually playing off of
that that term fake news and so that's
an attention grabber so I think that's
what makes this look so good but this is
a single image at and you can see here
they're promoting this ad with a
promotion so try 12 weeks for just 36
euros okay so they have a promotion in
there so and you notice they the image
of the you know the magazine they're
also displaying that hey you can look at
this digitally on a laptop a tablet or a
mobile phone so you have other options
as well so they show you that in the
image which is placed on the right side
of their messaging so me this is a good
ad because of the placement of the image
the type of image they're using the play
on fake news and the promotion that
they're offering up so this is really a
good ad it's very eye-catching and
hopefully the promotion's good enough to
get you to sign up okay so tip number 6
so tip number 6 we want to continue
seriously do a be testing you want to
always have this option going for you
you want to be able to test variation a
versus variation B because you want to
be able to find out what works and what
doesn't work with your audience and on
top of that it helps you really put your
best foot forward by showing your best
ad so by doing a/b testing you're
getting feedback from the audience and
turning that feedback into positive
returns so you're then turning your ad
that does work well in front of an
audience and you're going to continue to
do that so a B testing is always a good
option so remember when you're setting
up your ad in Facebook go ahead and
choose to have your a/b tests set up and
when you do that you choose that option
you're gonna be able to then go in and
choose what it is you want to test with
that a and then with that B so you're
going to again align your test with a
Facebook page you're gonna choose an ad
format once you choose your ad format
then you're gonna be able to go ahead
and you know put your ad in there and
then you're going to choose your
call-to-action
so the whole idea behind an a/b test is
you want to be able to find what it is
you want to test is that gonna be the
call to action isn't going to be the
messaging is it going to be the ad
format so there are lots of things you
could test with Facebook on a/b testing
so it's all part of the ads setup so
things you can change again are the
color of the elements imaging text the
call-to-action the position of the ad
there's lots of things you could test
that's all part of the Facebook setup so
the thing is you want to continuously
test that's the key continuously test
certain elements of an ad so testing can
be done initially on broader elements
and then smaller finer details like
statements and your on coffee so my
advice is when you're actually sending
this up on Facebook you know think ahead
think what it is you want to choose to
test my advice is maybe start out with a
call to action so if you're in facebook
itself you know you have an opportunity
to test different call to action try
that that's an easy way to test and then
you know when you test the call to
action once you find out what works and
doesn't work then you can move on to
something more sophisticated
like maybe the image type or maybe
trying different types of imagery or ad
types like the carousel versus single
image so start small start easy and then
work your way up tip number seven so we
want to choose an appropriate call to
action in your advertisements that will
attract potential customers so what do
we mean well you have different call to
actions available to you you want to
choose one that aligns with your ad so
for example to simply learn ad about hey
learn how SEO works search engine
optimization so if you're trying to get
somebody to you know learn or take one
of your courses you're not asking them
to actually shop now you really want
them to sign up so that's the key we
want them to sign up so use a call to
action that makes sense
tip number eight choose the right
audience for your advertisement okay so
what do we mean so for this you can
consider you know website visits
interest all depends on your objective
okay what is it you want people to do if
it's you know customers in the buying
process then that's our objectives to
get conversions then we want to move
somebody over to a product page and get
them to purchase you know if it's
focusing on just website visits then
maybe it's the objective of
consideration maybe you just want to get
people to your website to learn more
about your product so that's the whole
idea behind you know choosing the right
you know objective because you want to
align the objective with your ad ok so
tip number nine create look-alike
audiences and I'd like like audience
because what Facebook does is they
create an audience that's similar to the
audience you already advertising to or
customer base you already have so in
other words Facebook already has an idea
of who your audiences you can also you
know provide them with additional
information like an email list to give
them a better sense of who your audience
is and then what Facebook does is they
take that information and they'll put
your ad in front of it audience that
looks just like the audience you already
have that's why they call it a
look-alike on it so it's a great feature
by Facebook it really allows you to
reach
target audience an audience is very
similar to the audience you currently
have one example provide Facebook with
an email list with that email list
they're gonna be able to map that email
list and be able to identify an audience
that you could target so that's the
whole idea behind look-alike audience is
a great feature by Facebook definitely
recommend taking advantage of that why
because it will increase the number of
people who will find your advertisement
relevant remember you're targeting
people who are similar to your actual
audience to your the people who are
already connected with your brand or
already liking your page so if they're
similar to those people then the chances
of them engaging with you are gonna be
greater
so look-alike audiences tend to perform
well because you're targeting an
audience is very similar to your actual
audience tip number 10 so use the golden
point rule on your ad creative so what
do we mean by golden point rule well
let's take this ad here as an example
what we want to do is we want to divert
the creative into nine equally sized
boxes so what we want to do is draw two
horizontal lines and two vertical lines
just like a tic-tac-toe box and so
ideally what we want to do is place the
main subject of your ad in the cross
sections of the drawn lines and so what
that does is encourages the user to
place their focus on those points the
lines are just simply there is a
guidance to help you position your
messaging so that's the golden point
rule really is we want to be able to
position our messaging accordingly so
time for another ad break so let's take
a look at another ad here on Facebook
and this one's by blue apron and so of
all the tips we've talked about this
particular ad takes into account a lot
of them okay so this is again they're
using multiple images in this ad here
again what they're doing promotion
they're offering up a $30 off promotion
here and what they're asking you to do
is sign up to get that $30 off so you
can see the call to action we already
mentioned that on one of our tips the
call to action matches the ad so they're
asking to sign up they're using really
good imagery
here and there supporting that with you
know some good copy and text so this is
what makes this ad so good I mean who
doesn't like good-looking food or tasty
food and healthy food okay so they're
definitely taking advantage of the
imagery with a promotion and with a good
call to action and so remember we want
to a be test so blue apron is likely
testing this ad so what they could do
with this is test different imagery or
they could test a different promotion so
there's a lot they can do here on the
a/b testing side so for me if I were to
test this yeah I would probably be
testing the imageries because we want to
be able to see what images get people to
sign up alternatively we can also test
the offer as well
what offer is gonna get somebody to
click on that signup button so ideally
there's a lot to do here from the a/b
test standpoint and the way they've
structure this ad it makes it very easy
to test so that's what makes this ad
really good is shows good imagery has a
good promotion and aligns the CTA tip
number 11 so we want to place the
product in the right hand of your
creative so the right side should
contain our product imagery so why is
that why because there's been a study
called the perceived product heaviness
and package evaluation and that states
that depending on where a product is
place users would react differently to
it and so the study found that users
tend to react more positively when the
product is placed on the right side of
the I creative so here you can see
countdown to Black Friday this is an
Amazon related ad and you can see the
product is basically a litter box which
is placed on the right side so it's a
black friday Ad they didn't place the
image on the left side they placed on
the right side because people tend to
react positively when the product image
is on the right side so keep that in
mind when you're placing your imagery
try to place it on the right side tip
number 12
don't use images that have more than 20%
text okay so you want to use images that
are clean we remember that blue apron
image we looked at and that was a very
clean image of food no text overlaying
the image
so we want to try and stay away from
images that have text on the overlay
okay so there's no limit to how much
text you can add to your creative but
your Facebook and myself recommend hey
the lesser text you have the more likely
it is for your ad to have its desired
impact meaning somebody's gonna click on
that ad okay so keep that in mind let
the image do the talking for you you
don't necessarily need to overwhelm the
image with words or messages tip number
13 so we want to use an ad creative
that's attention-grabbing and is
relevant for your business so again
going back to that blue apron ad
hey who doesn't like good-looking food
good-looking healthy food green food
well
switching gears we're looking at a Nike
ad who doesn't like a good looking shoe
here this is a good running shoe and
Nike is definitely taking advantage of
the opportunity to place the shoe
against a nice-looking background so
here are the image on the left you got a
nice mob looking color the shoe on the
right on a nice red background to kind
of really play into the color of the
shoe and so that's attention grabbing so
the color is kind of match and go with
one another and it tends to grab your
attention
so Nikes doing a good job here I'm just
not showing an image of a shoe really
what they're doing is put the shoe is
the central focal point and supporting
that with additional color and they're
really putting the messaging kind of as
the background behind the shoe so
they're making that as a attention
grabbing as possible here the Nikes done
a good job with this ad you know meet
persley I'm not the biggest Nike fan
when it comes to shoes but hey this I'd
definitely grab my attention because now
I could see you know this shoe is really
popping to me we don't want to use clip
art in your act creative okay and don't
use low resolution pixelated images as
well we want to use high quality imagery
so and use images that are well lit you
know natural lighting always tends to
work well as well so when you're doing a
placement for product whether that be
food or shoe you can see here in this
plated example they're putting it on the
right image to put
National Environment on a table on a
plate with some paper next to it you
know and then you can see from the one
on the left
it's of a person holding a box with the
image of plated on it and said to me
that's not stock imagery or clipart you
know that's an actual person holding the
product so it's real life you want to
make it as real life as possible and as
clear and quality as possible so when
you create attention-grabbing ads you
show images of people benefitting from
your product that of just having the
product itself so that's always a good
idea in the case of coca-cola you know
these people are enjoying their bottle
of coca-cola well going back to the Nike
ad you know they could have had a person
wearing that shoe or you know running
with that shoe that could have been an
alternative for them as well so the
whole idea is just make sure your ads or
attention-getting and they grab your
attention and if you're gonna use people
make sure the persons enjoying it just
like on the previous image the person
holding the box we could see she's got a
smile in her face and she is enjoying
holding that box so to me you want to
use people with the images to the best
of your ability and that means use that
person who's enjoying it so that's
really gonna put the product in the
forefront okay tip 14 don't hesitate to
experiment with your advertisements
creative or it's copy okay so what do we
mean by that really we want to be
refreshing our text we want to be
refreshing our images okay so if you're
gonna place an ad on Facebook don't let
that be the only ad okay if you're using
a single image ad you know feel free to
change out that single image from time
to time especially if a lot of people
have seen that ad so if you're using
reach as your objective and you're
trying to reach as many people as
possible just keep in mind that if that
ad is reaching the same people over and
over again it's going to get stale and
you want to be able to update that out
so if you're free to change out the
imagery changing out the text is just as
easy
okay so feel free to play around with
the text even you're not doing a/b
testing you can always change out the
just to see hey if changing out the text
actually gets you better engagement or
meet your goals tip 15 plan your
campaigns for the holiday season okay so
Kent State this enough you know towards
you know October November December that
tends to be a lot of holidays
you know across multiple religions okay
so it's really the time of year where
people are in full ad mode and audiences
are in full watch mode so advertisers
are really pushing ads that time of year
especially Christmas you know and people
are accepting of that because they're
used to it so you want to be able to
plan accordingly so if you do in your
ads you can easily engage with your
audience if you are lining your ad with
that time of year so during Christmas
most people are in the mood for shopping
so it's a time of year where you can
really really really take advantage of
increasing your sales increasing your
conversions so you want to plan
accordingly and so if you're planning
you know months in advance
you don't have to do a full year but you
know for me if I'm thinking I'm gonna do
a lot of advertising during the holiday
season
I'm probably gonna go out maybe once
summer ends probably August beginning of
September beginning to September seasons
change little I might start thinking
about the holiday season and when you
could plan appropriately you can come
out with really good ads you think about
what you want to say and so in this case
you know target this particular ad is
really promoting Black Friday so Black
Friday is the day after Thanksgiving in
the United States and so here they're
letting you know Black Friday's here and
there's deals to be had so planning in
advance gives you an opportunity to
really really tweak your messaging and
come up with some good creative ideas so
let's take another break and let's look
at another good-looking ad this example
we're gonna look at Dell okay so dough
I've seen their ads all over Facebook
they do a lot of different advertising
types between videos carousels and this
is a single image ad they're really
trying to do is
you over to the storefront so you can
buy one of these good-looking you know
Dell computers okay so you know here
again they're promoting their latest
computer the Dell Inspiron 3000 series
all-in-one desktop so to them anytime
they create a new product they're gonna
go out and put out a new ad for that
product and here they're putting a
little bit of a different twist on it if
you notice the ad itself is just the
image of the product there's really no
promotion here they're letting the
product image speak for itself they're
really showing you hey look how good
this computer looks you know this is our
new model and you know we got a SHOP NOW
CTA so if you're interested go ahead and
click on that shop now so they're really
putting the effort into the image itself
you know they're not offering any
promotion you know no discounts you know
what you see is what you get with the
image and you click on it you're going
to go right to their storefront so Dell
does a good job of really you know
cranking out their new products whenever
they go to market so tip 16 shortly
amount of time between retargeting your
audience so target people have visited
your website within the span of a month
or two weeks so retargeting is reaching
out to people who you've already engaged
with so if somebody has seen your ad or
somebody's went to your website
somebody's even purchased from you
before you have the opportunity to reach
back out to that person so how often you
reach out to that person or how long
between their initial engagement and
when you retarget them really does
depend on what it is you're selling so
if you're selling a pair of shoes if
your Nike then chances are somebody's
looking for pair of shoes it's not going
to be a long purchase window meaning
they're not going to wait two three
months so if I'm nine and if somebody's
seen my ad I'm probably gonna target
that person in a short period of time
for retargeting so really depends on
your product but you don't want to wait
too long between the time they've been
get initially engaged and the time you
retarget so it really depends on your
product you know again if you're selling
merchandise
you know retail it's probably going to
be a smaller time frame
if you're Dell computers you know that's
a bigger purchase somebody's gonna take
their time so you know you want to
target people you know for their Dell
computer probably you know over a longer
period of time
okay so just keep the product in mind
you don't want to wait too long you
don't want to keep it too short so you
want to find that nice balance of when
you could retarget someone okay tip
number 17
keep altering the hook of your ad copy
what do we mean by altering the hook so
here you can see a couple of different
options option one you know we're
talking about hey if you're interested
in getting some DMCA certification you
know this is what you need to do option
two a little bit different of a hook a
start your journey to get your DMC CA
certification so you know just all train
the way you're trying to talk to
somebody is really what we're after here
on tip number 17
you haven't had especially the text
remember we always want to refresh that
copy but it's you're testing it tried
different hooks try different ways to
talk to people okay it always works well
when you can have different types of
messaging because people react to
different messaging so in effect the
strategy would be to create multiple ads
with different hooks and see what
performs best so this is an option for
a/b testing okay you have an option to
add messaging go ahead and talk one way
in one option and then you know tweak
that messaging tweak that hook a bit an
option B and see what resonates with
people so that's a good option for a/b
testing as always you know look at the
way you're going to try and you know get
somebody to convert tip number 18 okay
respond to lead add responses as soon as
possible so remember one of your ad
formats is Ali dad okay so if you have
Ali dad basically what you're asking
somebody do is add their name their
phone number their email if you get that
information don't sit on it react to it
just like the messaging the facebook
messenger how it's almost instantaneous
think of the lead ads the same way okay
you have somebody who's engaging with
your ad by providing information you
don't want to sit on it
you want to respond as soon as possible
in fact you know when you do engage that
person let them know you're available on
Facebook messenger so they can actually
then reach out to you via Facebook
messenger just to expedite the
communication but when you get that
valuable information from the customer
you know respond as soon as possible
it's good customer service because the
longer you take to respond the less
likely the customer will want to
continue interacting with you so there's
no real good rule of thumb here except
for do it as soon as possible okay tip
number 19 ad scarcity to your
advertisements so what do we mean by
that well in this example we could see
the top 100 registrations get free
access so by putting this into your ad
copy we're hoping your prospects are
more inclined to buy your product due to
that they're that they're not going to
be one of the first 100 registrations
okay so it allows you to really put some
sense of urgency in the ad to get
somebody to react oh so that's what we
mean by you know scarcity okay so by
doing so it could affect the long-term
credibility you know we don't want to
come across as fear-mongering by any
means but hey if your promotion is the
first 100 registrations get free access
then why not you know go ahead and put
it in there some other examples could be
you know only three days left to
register or first 50 get 50% off or you
know hurry now there's only two days
left so there's other language you can
put to play around with the language but
if you only have certain slots available
or certain amount of days left there's
nothing wrong with putting that in the
ad copy to get people to react and so
that's the whole idea behind you know
the scarcity is you want to be able to
let people know hey there's a limited
edition going on here you're interested
go ahead and take advantage tip number
20 keep track of your add relevant
scores so your ads do get scored so the
score ranges from one to ten okay so
what that score does is it's an
indicator to signify the quality and
engagement levels so you know
your scores between one and six then the
ad isn't reaching the relevant audience
and your audience isn't reacting to it
however if your relevant score is
between seven and ten then your ads are
reaching the appropriate audience and
you're getting a lot of interaction so
keep an eye on that you know the lower
the number that means hey we're not gay
our ads not getting to the right
audience and if it's not getting to the
right audience our audience isn't going
to react to it
so it all starts with making sure you're
reaching your audience with your app
when your ad is reaching your audience
and you're doing a/b testing your
audience is going to react to one of
those two ads so that's always gonna
help your relevant score so keep an eye
on that relevant score okay so let's
take another break here and let's take a
look at an ad here by Blue Bottle coffee
okay so I'm a big coffee drinker myself
my frequent bluebottle in San Francisco
a lot and so here this is a nice image a
nice close-up image of coffee and I
really like this notice there's really
no comma action here okay so they're
putting their website URL the domain
Blue Bottle coffee com they're saying
hey we source great coffees we roast
them to perfection and get them to you
fresh so I can vouch for that really
putting their brand out there okay so
this is more of a brand awareness
tie-back that's their objective their
objective is if you've going to drink
coffee at some other location or with
some other brand hey take a look at ours
you know we got good coffee too we roast
them pretty good and and we make sure
that you get them fresh that's what
they're trying to do they're trying to
introduce their brand to you so this is
a good example of a brand awareness ad
single image ad they're definitely
making use of the adage of the image
itself you know with a nice close-up
shot of that roasted coffee so that's
what makes this adds a special brand
awareness you know the image is telling
us hey this coffee looks pretty pretty
good it looks nice and roasted it looks
pretty fresh and maybe I'll get Blue
Bottle coffee a try so that's why
they're putting their domain
okay so it's a good brand awareness ad
and the hope is to convert some people
over to their brand
okay so tip number 21 include emojis in
your ad copy
okay so emojis we know are popular you
use them in text use them on social
media I mean there's hundreds of emojis
nowadays that you could pick and choose
from they are really specific and so
here you can see in the cases simply
learn hey if you're taking a digital
marketing course or simply learn it
doesn't hurt to have some emoji support
that that message so you always got the
thumbs up to get emoji you know the
image of the graduation and that's a
good emoji so you know you always want
to align you know really fun relevant
emojis with your messaging and it kind
of just helps it stick out a bit and
people resonate with emojis and so it
doesn't hurt to add those emojis in your
ad copy and especially if your
competition is not using emojis you want
every advantage you can to have your ad
stick out so emojis is a good way to get
your ad to stick out tip number 22 use
UTM parameters to your ad which can feed
into your Google Analytics account and
provide tracking information so I can't
stress this enough if you're using
Google Analytics to track your campaigns
then you want to use UTM parameters so
what do we mean by UTM parameters well
let me show you an example so all you
need to do is type in UTM tracking or
URL builder in Google and you're gonna
actually get to this page here so what
this does this is a tool to help you
create UTM tracking so if we're simply
learn and we want to advertise and drive
the audience to a specific page in this
case artificial intelligence master's
program page so this is going to be the
URL but we want to append that URL with
some UTM tracking parameters our
campaign source parameter we're gonna
put Facebook because that's the source
of what we're advertising the medium in
which we're driving that traffic to the
page from facebook is CPC which stands
for cost per click and then we're just
going to put
name AI engineer to identify what it is
that campaign is related to so notice
that the only required parameter is
campaign source in this case we're going
to put Facebook but we can also use
campaign content if we want to
differentiate the different ads that we
have so you can use campaign content
parameter as well you don't have to the
only required parameters campaign source
my recommendation go all lowercase okay
and then when you're done you have a URL
that you can use and your advertising so
when somebody actually goes that URL
notice the URL includes the UTM tracking
and then analytics is going to be able
to pick up that campaign from where
Facebook the medium is gonna be CPC and
the campaign in this case it's gonna be
AI engineer and that's what you're going
to look for in Google Analytics so it
helps you track your ads more closely
because if you don't use you team
tracking for example on Facebook then
analytics might you know interpret that
traffic coming from that ad as you know
organic social so we want to be able to
identify specifically to campaign you're
running by putting in different
variables for those parameters so that's
what UTM tracking is you want to use it
for all your Facebook advertising okay
so it really helps you you know an
analytics identify how your campaign is
performing not only is it driving
traffic but is the campaign converting
for you so if you're trying to get
somebody to sign up for a class then
analytics is going to help us measure
those conversions but with UTM tracking
we can bridge the gap between how many
people Facebook delivered or drove to
our site from the ad and how many of
those people actually convert it so UTM
parameters help bridge that gap tip 23
use exclusion marketing to improve your
Facebook return on investment by not
including people who have already taken
the action desired by you okay so this
is a very key feature here so if we've
already advertised and people have
reacted to our ad and has subscribed
they have subscribed and we don't want
to target that person again so that's
what exclusion mark
we want to be able to you know target
people that were really after so if you
know somebody's looked at our ad and did
not convert or do not go to our website
or to not download something or whatever
it is we wanted them to do then those
are the people we wanted to focus in on
okay so in this case exclusion marketing
we're gonna exclude people who have
subscribed in this case we're gonna
retarget people meaning advertise again
to people who have not subscribed so
that's what the exclusion marketing
feature does it helps you really hone in
on where you're targeting and
retargeting so that way you're not
hitting the same people over again and
that's only gonna lead to poor
performance tip 24 track the right
metrics for your business so keep your
eye on important metrics one of those
metrics you know there's going to be
kpi's KPIs or key performance indicators
and KPIs differentiate from metrics
because KPIs are related to business
goals so track the right metrics for
your business what are the right metrics
for your business more than likely it's
going to be conversions or conversion
rate but you could be running a brand
awareness campaign just like Blue Bottle
coffee coffee did and so if you're
running a brand awareness campaign then
maybe your KPI or metric is gonna be a
click OK or click-through rate how many
people are actually reacting to our ad
okay so you always want to align the
right metric with your business okay
it's just very important that you're
measuring against the right metric if
you're not then it's going to be
misaligned in terms of how you judge the
campaign performance another set of
metrics could be reach and frequency so
reach and frequency allow us to measure
how many people saw the ad and post
engagement can determine how many users
are reacting to your ads CPC helps us
determine the cost effectiveness or how
much we're paying for every click you
could see that information and your
Facebook ad manager for example if I go
to face
ads manager here I'm looking at some
some ads that we're running here what
can I see I could see my reach how many
people I'm actually reaching the
frequency in which they're seeing my ad
notice I can see my relevancy score I
can also see my cost per results I could
see the total clicks so I have a whole
set of metrics available to me really
what I want to do is pick and choose the
metrics that are most important to the
atom running okay so if it's reach am i
reaching the full amount of people
possible if I'm running a brand
awareness campaign or make it be some
other metric like conversions so we want
to be able to align the right metric
with the right ad tip 25 take advantage
of Facebook's location tracking tool for
your advertisements so Facebook allows
us to advertise up to 25 countries with
different states provinces cities
districts and zip codes so we can really
hone in location wise on where we want
to target so Facebook allows us to do
that so basically it could be somebody
in a particular area or people who have
been recently been there or traveling to
that location or actually lived there so
really could hone in on a specific
location based on certain set of
criteria so with this you could take
your marketing to the next level by
poaching your competitors customers by
offering them better discounts so that's
the whole idea
targeting your advertising on a specific
location and then knowing that your
competitors are there you can really put
out some really good ads with some
really good offers to really convert
some of those people in that audience
okay let's take a look at another ad
okay so
grammarly this is an ad that they've put
out there and again you notice there's
no real true call-to-action associated
with the single image ad here it's all
about messaging here they're saying hey
download it free today okay and so it's
a browser extension that they're
promoting and really they're trying to
get you to identify or identify with
this particular brand that offers of
specific products so they do have a
promotion in there it's brand awareness
hey your life is about to
Chiang I mean the message is pretty you
know matter of fact they're trying to
get you to hey I need this in my browser
as an extension so for me this ad is all
about the messaging here okay so with
grammarly you know if you're in Gmail
you're in word you're an Outlook they
got you covered by using their browser
extension it's free and by using it it's
gonna make your life a lot easier so for
me the ad works from a messaging
standpoint not really big on the imagery
but it's really about this is who we are
and we can really rock your world if you
use this browser extension so they're
really putting a lot of emphasis on the
messaging so for me anytime somebody
says my lies about to change that
they've got my attention
so I went over 25 tips and strategies
for you on Facebook if you have any
questions please feel free to comment
below the video I want to thank you for
your attention and if you need any more
information please visit simply learn
comm thank you hi there if you like this
video subscribe to the simple learn
YouTube channel and click here to watch
similar videos standard up and get
certified click here